filtre des propos qui mettent le feu aux
poudres chez des policiers en début de
semaine christophe castaner annonce
l'abandon de la clé d'étranglement lors
des interpellations
une déclaration à laquelle s'ajoute une
longue tirade sur le racisme dans la
police j'ai pour nos forces de l'ordre
une exigence particulière et une
intransigeance plus forte encore le
racisme n'a pas sa place dans notre
société et encore moins dans notre
police républicaine
ces dernières semaines trop ont failli
dans leurs devoirs républicains
les propos racistes ont été proférées
les discriminations révélé c'est
inacceptable
alors nous avons agi en conséquence
systématiquement je veux une tolérance
zéro contre le racisme dans notre
république
je veux que chacun sache que quand on
porte l'uniforme l'uniforme bleu de la
loi on ne se situe jamais au dessus
d'elle un message qui a du mal à passer
auprès des forces de l'ordre en réponse
plusieurs syndicats de police organise
des manifestations partout en france
entre jeudi et vendredi
l'image qui fait le tour des médias se
jeter de menottes pour marquer le
mécontentement des policiers autres
actions chez les forces de l'ordre ce
défilé sur les champs-elysées à paris
zones habituellement interdites aux
manifestations
parallèlement plusieurs syndicats de
police ont été reçus au ministère de
l'intérieur ce jeudi mais pour l'unité
sgp fo christophe castaner a perdu la
confiance des forces de l'ordre ses
propos de lundi soir dans son point
presse dans sa conférence de presse sans
inacceptables notamment et vous l'avez
fort bien relaté en présentation
notamment à travers la suppression selon
ses dires du atteignit du contrôle de
tête communément appelées oat clé
d'étranglement
mais c'est un contrôle de tête c'est
comme ça a été mes collègues ont été
formés ces conseils j'ai été formé le
ministre est très claire sur le soupçon
avérée
on tourne une page c'est un propos
maladroits et il le reconnaît il l'a
déjà dit dans les médias il nous l'a
redit évidemment que c'est pas le
soupçon qui condamne le policier c'est
la faute donc là dessus premier point
balayé on lui a fait savoir qu'il n'est
pas question de se retrouver dans une
zone grise avec des techniques
d'interpellation qui ne sont plus
possibles parce qu'elles ont été
interdites
donc il est conscient de ce problème
vendredi dans la soirée
christophe castaner envoie une lettre
aux syndicats de policiers en colère
dans un communiqué de la place beauvau
il rappelle son soutien total aux forces
de police
il n'a jamais été question de remettre
en cause la présomption d'innocence à
laquelle policiers et gendarmes ont
évidemment droit comme tout un chacun
ce samedi le ministre de l'intérieur se
rend dans un commissariat de
mantes-la-jolie dans les yvelines pour
rendre hommage à un couple de policiers
tués quatre ans plus tôt à turin et
tenter de regagner la confiance des
forces de l'ordre